we play that clip with Megan Kelly and
Trump making Kelly as president this
question here's Trump's answer that's
got a lot of people on the right upset
can a man become a woman
[Music]
in my opinion
give a man you have a woman I I think I
think part of it is birth can the man
give birth no no although they'll come
up with something still no and
everybody's always like Vinnie you're
such a trump guess what I don't like
that answer say what you got why is that
because he's on the fence he doesn't
want to piss off that certain group for
for that for the voting and it's like
you should right then and there I think
that should have been a moment where he
goes your men are men and women are
women that's it and that come move on
kind of going like because obviously he
wants to make everybody happy he's
running for president that answer I
don't like I don't like that he got to
step up at him and say no men are men
and women are women no men I fully
disagree with you I'll tell you why why
if there's anybody that's not worried
about making everybody happy it's Donald
Trump he he don't give a everything
he talks about is these you know fascist
Democrat left he don't give two shits
about the outside of the owl right now
he's running in a primary and running
away with it I agree with you that he
should just be like yeah I don't play
this game what the hell are we talking
about there should have been no um no
pause so I agree with you that he should
have doubled down on this yes and
whether it's Dylan Mulvaney or Bud Light
or whatever but like unacceptable
because that's what his base wants so
I'm just saying he's not trying to what
I disagree with you he's not trying to
appease everybody he should be trying to
appease his base yeah the question
before that in the interview I didn't
realize that was two weeks ago but I
watched it last night was about Caitlyn
Jenner and you know he's like the first
time we ran he goes this wasn't even an
issue in 2016. yeah Caitlyn Jenner she
wants to use the female bathroom I don't
really give a whatever he's like I
knew Bruce when he was a man beautiful
beautiful man athletes great guy you
know he was like As Trump does Bruce
said he had full surgeries exactly so
he's not trans not cross-dressing Bruce
said I've had full quote the ship has
sailed my surgery I'm complete so
shout out that was the quote that's what
Caitlyn said to the day
shout out to your dick so the point is
this I think Trump it's it's actually
like put yourself in Trump's position
forget about talking points forget about
what your base wants to hear
what the hell are we even like is it a
man a woman or like this is something
he's so not used to yeah but actually
you know if you see him on the campaign
Trail at his rallies he's you know men
or men women are women he's doing this
yeah I don't know if it was just a
glitch a pause he was just kind of
because he's usually very antagonistic
by the way shout out to Trump going on
Megan Kelly going on MSNBC go taking the
tough questions like CNN with Kate and
Collins like one thing like you have to
respect about Trump
whether you like him or don't like him
the dude shows up there's no chance that
Joe Biden is sitting down there with
Megan Kelly for an hour Fielding tough
questions Joe Biden won't do that for
five minutes
it's one of those things where you know
Trump
I understand why people don't like him
and I understand why people like him
like it's a double like two things can
be true go for it I I think he should
have been definitive he's always been
definitive and that's what his base
wants be definitive why would have been
so difficult for him to say Megan why
are we talking about this
children are born male or female later
in life they want to have sex change we
have a controversy people want to
cross-dress and call themselves trans
that says
if you have a sex change surgery like
Caitlyn Jenner did okay then maybe
you're part of the way there you still
can't give birth but I don't know why
we're having this conversation what is
this question Tom I've heard you do a
better Trump before no but that's all he
had to say and by the way we know what
the base would say thank you yeah and it
doesn't give a lot to the other side
it's like boom Pat how would you have
responded to that basic question what is
a woman I mean it's not even a question
for me I don't even know why we're
having a conversation for me it would
have been a different answer but Trump
uh uh Trump is Trump Trump's going to
give whatever answer he wants to give
and there is always strategy in his he
could have had a conversation with this
Camp 30 minutes prior to that that maybe
one of his advisors told him something
that in his mind he's trying to put his
next move together on the way he's going
to answer and the way he's going to have
a rebuttal to this he's a strategist his
brain is always going on what he's going
to be doing and at the same time uh the
audience right now like the scientist if
the Santa's needed a victory
in the last how long four months three
months he just had a victory this week
yeah this has so far been a good week
for DeSantis his response to Kevin
McCarthy and Trump what he just said to
Megan Kelly last week so in the last 10
days this has been a good week for her
let's see if that changes the polls at
all it won't do anything and when the
debate is next week I want to say in
California California
um by the way Megan Kelly she is
actually a full on real journalist okay
she was asking tough questions she was
respectful we all know what happened in
2016 when she's like you've called dot
women dogs pigs whatever he's like only
Rosie O'Donnell yeah they addressed it
it was very interesting uh but she is
classy and uh of first class journalist
but like he was a Jones she was a lawyer
with Joan's dad because I think that was
the interview was this interview where
she asked about the abortion and the
time and the date or 15 weeks or
something like that yes and he still was
like well we're I don't like he's like
you said I would get people from both
sides and then we would come down with a
plan exactly that's for everybody
because what he's doing it he saw that
the abortion what the Supreme Court did
right before the midterms didn't wasn't
what would women in America so he's he's
adjusting based on the case study he saw
with midterms midterms revealed a lot to
form of where America's at today and he
wants to win so for him he's looking at
strategies on how to win the election so
if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
foreign
[Music]